-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
Let's get to the news.
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
spoke yesterday
on the Senate floor
and said that the U.S.
is getting
"dangerously close
to hitting the debt ceiling,"
which is scary because there has
never been a group of people
less likely to spontaneously
raise the roof.
President Biden had lunch today
with Vice President
Kamala Harris,
and even that bill
couldn't get figured out.
In a new interview,
ex-U.N. ambassador Nikki Haley
said that she calls former
President Trump a friend,
while Trump calls her Linda.
The U.S. Capitol Police
yesterday forcibly removed a man
from a suspicious SUV parked
outside of the Supreme Court.
They knew something was off
when the back window
didn't have this sticker on it.
That's right --
The Capitol Police removed a man
from a suspicious SUV parked
outside of the Supreme Court.
The man was apparently
so suspicious,
Republicans want him
on the Supreme Court.
Facebook released a statement
yesterday
explaining the cause of Monday's
six-hour-long outage.
And, man, she is screwing
everything up lately.
"I unplugged the server
so I could charge my phone.
Not sorry."
Singer Adele announced yesterday
she'll release a new single
called "Easy on Me"
later this month.
Incidentally, a new single
is also who's going to
listen to it the most.
[ Laughter ]
Poor lady, take a stock photo.
She's like,
"This will never come up."
[ Laughter ]
"They won't use this one."
More apartments in Manhattan
sold in the third quarter
of this year
than any other time
in the last 32 years.
So now the only affordable
neighborhood in New York
is WeHu,
meaning west of the Hudson,
and, yeah, sorry,
it's New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
You have a view of Manhattan.
The fast-food chain Wendy's
announced a partnership
with Kellogg's yesterday
to release a chocolate
Frosty-flavored cereal.
Not to be outdone, McDonald's
is releasing a McFlurry cereal
that is temporarily
out of service.
And finally, according to
the latest rankings,
former President Trump
is no longer
on "Forbes" magazine's list
of the 400 richest Americans,
but on the bright side,
he still made the list
of the 46 greatest presidents.
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.